[Music]
a grim end to a massive search this
Thursday night pieces of the missing
submersible found near the wreck of the
Titanic the debris is consistent with
the catastrophic loss
of the pressure chamber what may have
happened on the unforgiving ocean floor
as five lives are lost and could this
have been avoided we speak with an
expert who warned about ocean Gates
experimental approach gone in an instant
those who died in the Manitoba bus crash
are identified hearts are broken
families are grieving Community is
feeling immeasurable loss plus hope in a
time of War
visit a Ukrainian Village more than a
year after Russia invaded how
found a way to keep living
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us all
hope has now been lost for the five
people on board the submersible that
went missing in the North Atlantic Ocean
including the man who founded the
company Ocean Gate the U.S Coast Guard
announced today a remotely operated
vehicle has found a debris field on the
ocean floor that is consistent with what
it calls a catastrophic implosion of the
vessel
we found
five different major pieces of of debris
that uh
told us that it was the
remains of the Titan I offer my deepest
condolences to the families
I Can Only Imagine
what this has been like for them
and I hope that this discovery
provides some soulless
the Titan submersible seen here in 2021
launched on Sunday Bound for the wreck
of the Titanic that lies almost four
kilometers under the surface a trip
wealthy patrons on board paid hundreds
of thousands of dollars for contact was
lost one hour and 45 minutes into
Sunday's dive Ocean Gate the company
that built the submersible calls the
five men explorers who shared a spirit
of Adventure and in a statement said our
hearts are with these five souls and
every member of their families during
this tragic time we grieve the loss of
the life and joy they brought to
everyone they knew Mike Armstrong is in
Saint John's where many of the ships and
the crews involved in the search base
themselves Mike this isn't the outcome
anyone wanted how was the debris
discovered well Donna it was a Canadian
ship that set off from the harbor here
in St John's yesterday that made the
discovery of the Arctic Horizon launched
a remotely operated vehicle this morning
and found what everyone's been looking
for
the Coast Guard says it found a first
debris field 500 meters off the bow of
the Titanic in it there were five
different major pieces including the
nose cone they then found another
smaller debris field in that one they
found the AFT end Bell basically both
ends of the Titan have been found the
debris is consistent with the
catastrophic loss
of the pressure chamber
upon this determination we immediately
notified the families now the Coast
Guard was asked if there's any way to
tell if the implosion would have been
above the Titanic or possibly from a
collision with the wreck it says the
location is fairly far away and in an
area with no Titanic debris as for when
it happened it was likely before the
search started otherwise the sound of
the Titan collapsing would have been
picked up by the sonar boys that have
been listening in recent days this was a
catastrophic implosion of the vessel
which would have generated a significant
Broadband sound now if things had gone
according to plan the Titan sub would
have headed here Memorial University's
Marine Institute about a half hour
outside St John's has a pier it's the
Titans home base before and after trips
to the Titanic wreck students work with
Ocean Gate Expeditions as part of a
partnership the Marine Institute isn't
talking right now oh gosh everybody I
know is for locals it's the only thing
they're talking about anything happening
on the ocean is very important everybody
here uh it's lifeblood for most
newfoundlanders and labradorians the
company that ran the tours issued a
statement after the announcement the men
were lost it says quote these men were
true explorers who shared a distinct
Spirit of adventure and a deep passion
for exploring and protecting the world's
oceans our hearts are with these five
souls and every member of their families
during this tragic time we grieve the
loss of life and joy they brought to
everyone they knew
the daughter of the French Maritime
expert killed on the Titan says if her
father's final resting place is with the
Titanic he died doing what he loved and
is now with the ship he spent much of
his life studying she says it's
reassuring that he's there
and that where he is he's happy really
foreign
the Coast Guard was asked about the
possibility of recovering remains from
the five men that is not a question that
they wanted to answer at the depths
where they were and the incredible
pressures that there are down there
there would sadly be almost nothing left
Donna
Mike Armstrong in St John's thanks there
are lots of questions about what went
wrong and about the vessel's safety it
wasn't certified systems had
malfunctioned on previous Dives the
ocean floor at such depths is where the
Titanic lies is an unforgiving Place
Eric Sorensen is looking into that part
of the story
an amazing engineering feat it was five
years ago that Stockton Rush christened
the Titan described as the largest
pressure vessel ever made it performed
amazing feats diving to the bottom of
the Atlantic but this time something
went wrong and experts had feared the
worst the problem at these depths were
talking pressures of nearly six thousand
pounds per square inch is that when
something goes wrong it goes
cataclysmically wrong it's a it's a
tragedy Don Muth is an advisor on
submarine engineering he admires what
they were trying to achieve a lot of the
things people are trying to do in these
extreme environments have not been done
before but he added that as the Titan
had not been classified he would not
have taken such a trip I highly value
life so I would
not go down in one that didn't have a uh
it wasn't classed personally all of our
test program has been about incremental
testing from the earliest days ocean
Gates founder emphasized safety
suggesting that Titan was designed to
make repeated Dives with people on board
but it was openly called experimental it
had not been certified by regulatory
bodies in the U.S or Canada and was
operating in international waters this
was a an Innovative new design utilizing
carbon fiber for a hole with a titanium
plug-in cap that was that was new and
unique it you know wasn't something that
had been certified that's that's a
different approach than than you know
myself or others in the community might
have taken before the news broke one
scientist was already calling for an
investigation Ocean Gate should be shut
down investigated to make sure that they
took all the necessary precautions we
have to take a look at what the ship was
able to do was it properly tested was it
properly designed Memorial University's
Ken leday was holding out hope but as
the tragic outcome was breaking new
questions arose there's a lot of factors
that could have potentially compromised
the structural Integrity certainly
there's going to be a lot of attention
to to what the standards are going to be
for for any future visits to that site
Don Muth says he hopes risk will be
taken into consideration more in the
future but that exploration will go on
man always wants to explore extreme
environments and I don't think you're
going to stop with that whatever the
scientific merits this catastrophe will
raise new doubts about deep sea
exploration and what some view as
extravagant and extreme tourism Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
a little later I'll talk to an expert on
underwater Vehicles who had warned Ocean
Gate about its approach his thoughts on
today's developments
in Dolphin Manitoba the names and faces
of all 16 people killed in last
Thursday's crash near Carberry have now
been revealed it was an emotional press
conference involving friends family and
First Responders Rosanna Hempel was
there
a row of empty easels at the front of
the room soon to Bear the faces of 16
lost in Thursday's crash one by one in
silence family members and First
Responders carried pictures of loved
ones past Margaret fercolo as Manitoba
RCMP officials read the names family
members listened quietly in the front
rows some wiping away tears
hearts are broken families are grieving
Community is feeling immeasurable loss
they were mothers grandmothers sisters
fathers grandfathers brothers and
friends all between the ages of 68 to 88
with connections to dolphin and the
surrounding areas nine more remain in
hospital with serious injuries the next
few days and weeks and months will be
difficult however I know that we will
never forget them
and as we heal I trust we will continue
to support each other and remember all
the good these wonderful people brought
to us
Manitoba RCMP inspector Lee Forte helped
notify and work with families he
commended them for their strength amid
an agonizing Wait For answers it's
extremely hard to put yourself in their
shoes because they're not just grieving
the loss of one person there's nothing
you can do to take away that pain and
the premier says support for families
and First Responders won't end today my
heart goes out to all of them
superintendent Jeff osmondson says the
main thing that's helped him cope is how
everyone came together
the passing motor set the scene
rural fire departments EMS police mental
health workers community members local
churches and of course the victims
families
coming together as the impact of the
loss will be forever felt we will
remember you mounties confirmed the
drivers of both the bus and the
transport truck have the proper
licensing mechanical analysis is ongoing
meanwhile dauphin's Ministerial
Association is hosting a public memorial
service at the Ukrainian Orthodox Hall
tonight they hope it gives the community
a place to come together grieve and
share stories Donna Rosanna hampel
thanks lives upended in Ukraine ahead we
returned to a village a year after it
was reduced to Rubble by Russia's War
foreign
Ukraine has attacked a key bridge
connecting the South to Russian occupied
Crimea Russia says long-range missiles
were used in the overnight strike that
left a gaping hole in one of two Bridges
they are the shortest routes from the
Crimean Peninsula to her son on the
southern front line as well as a main
Supply route for Russian forces the
Crimean Peninsula which Russia illegally
annexed in 2014 has increasingly become
a Target as Ukraine pushes to reclaim
territory when faced with hardship
people find a way to endure and in
Ukraine it's a pattern that sadly keeps
repeating last year Global News visited
a destroyed Village in the cherniere of
region and for the brunt of a Russian
Advance early on in The Invasion Crystal
gomancing and video journalist Bradham
lattim went back there recently to see
what's changed and how people are coping
since Russian forces retreated
rubble and debris the remnants of Holmes
old and damaged materials piled up along
the few roads around the Tiny Village of
novus and livka but in the center of the
community there's something new
containers linked together creating a
modular housing community shelter for
vulnerable residents
everything is fine the main thing is
that we help each other olha makarenko
and Gregory moved in in the fall with
the help of our interpreter Petro they
explained winter was tough the units
were cold and they often had to cook on
a little gas-powered Hot Plate the
electrical infrastructure was regularly
knocked offline by airstrikes on the day
we visited the power was on the fritz
possibly because of the heavy rain
we're alive and thank God their survival
is something to Marvel at the village is
close to the Russian Bella Russian and
border at the start of the full invasion
Nova salivka was nearly leveled when
Russian forces began launching aerial
attacks and streaming into Ukraine
Russians occupied large swaths of the
region and encircled the nearby city of
chernihif after many battles the area
was liberated in April 2022 when Global
News first visited the community in May
of that year a group of residents rushed
over thinking we were a charity bringing
food
a bread truck now makes regular visits
to ensure people get nourishment but
their souls are tortured I can't get it
out of my head the noises of flying
Rockets or airplanes is all in my head
it flies and falls and we see someone's
house on fire in spite of everything
their Hospitality overflows the couple
showed us around their new community
their unit is Tiny two sets of bunk beds
some shelves a little table and two
windows but it's what's on their phones
that they desperately wanted to share oh
beautiful their garden and daughter
their pride and joy
Nadia who we also met in 2022 took us
into her unit she loves to read and is
happy to have a few books everything
here has been given to her yeah
it's better than nothing she says in the
summer I lived in a barn she's
originally from Siberia but she's called
Ukraine home for the past 50 years tears
streak her face as she talks about what
she terms the Russian policy and the
suffering it's causing Ukraine this is
what's left of Nadia's home she wasn't
here when it was hit by a rocket she's
nearby and every once in a while stops
in to cut some fresh flowers
building a bouquet she chats and smiles
she can visit but it can't compare she's
homesick just across the road is where
olha and Greg hori once lived they also
return regularly to tend to their Garden
oh wait being so close to their old
lives bring Solace and sorrow they still
don't know when or if someone will help
them rebuild but they're grateful to
have a place to sleep and that they're
able to stay close to their neighbors
Crystal gemancing Global News Nova
saliva Ukraine
extreme weather in the U.S coming up the
intense hail storm that injured dozens
of concert goers in Colorado
this unbelievable hail storm hit concert
goers just outside Denver Colorado last
night people raced to find shelter as
hailstones some as big as apples pelted
down seven people were hospitalized and
as many as 90 more were treated on scene
the concert at the Red Rocks
Amphitheater was delayed twice because
of the storm and finally canceled six
tornadoes were also reported across the
state Wednesday night
similar weather swept through Northern
Texas last night where a tornado killed
four people and injured 10 others the
Twister struck Matador a town of 600
flattening dozens of homes and knocking
out power the disaster happened just one
week after a deadly tornado in Perryton
three hours North killed three people
and injured dozens more
well Texans are used to the heat but not
like this in June nearly every corner of
the state is in the midst of a crushing
Heat Wave temperatures have hit 48
degrees Celsius in some places
Kingsville near Corpus Christi topped 51
degrees and multiple heat records are
being broken including in northern
Mexico the National Weather Center says
temperatures could be even higher next
week and the high heat is forecast to
last into July
next an expert on underwater Vehicles
who warned about ocean Gates approach
reflects on what happened
back now to our top story the loss of
the Titans submersible that had been
missing since Sunday the U.S Coast Guard
says a debris field has been found near
the wreck of the Titanic indicating the
submersible with five people on board
imploded somewhere on its Journey Into
the Depths of the North Atlantic it's
not clear exactly what happened but back
in 2018 dozens of Industry experts
warned of safety concerns in a letter to
Ocean Gate CEO Stockton rush they said
they feared the experimental approach
adopted by Ocean Gate could result in
negative outcomes from minor to
catastrophic will Conan is a signatory
to that letter he's the chair of the
Marine technology society and he's with
me now Mr Conan given what we learned
today those warnings sound prophetic
well sadly uh this is the worst possible
outcome on something we were fearful of
and uh
here we are this is uh possibly the
biggest tragedy we've had in our
industry in 50 60 years so this is a
very sad day
wings so deep into the ocean almost four
kilometers to the Titanic wreck is not
for the timid what did you mean back in
2018 about ocean Gate's experimental
approach
it's a term of Industry Donna the
experimental approach so
look we we do know we do know how to
make deep submersibles experimental
refers to
not following the regulatory
safety review that is standard in the
industry we do have regulations we have
rules do you have to certify it and do
it the law says no if you build a
submersible for yourself
you don't have to
um Ocean Gate didn't have to because
they weren't selling the submersible
they were building it for themselves so
you get by that one by law you were an
expert in underwater Vehicle Systems and
deep Dives when you hear the Coast Guard
say catastrophic implosion what does
that say to you catastrophic implosion
means that the
there was so much energy
in reserve that the the moment it gave
it just went
the positive side of it in a way you
know we've been on pins and needles for
four days
uh I've had family members that have had
nightmares thinking of being trapped in
a dark confined space in a cold for four
days yeah and um I mean it's it's
extremely cruciated excruciating so this
would indicate that I mean this happened
in one thousandth of a second no one
would have had time to realize what was
going on so there was probably
God had mercy on our souls here on this
planet
a final question Mr Conan what message
do you have for others who may be
planning expeditions to the Titanic
expeditions to the Titanic well this is
definitely uh ex you know there there
are many many more interesting places in
the world
uh to its lore it's for sure
specifically for the Titanic it's been
controversial for years for many for
many reasons but look the the message is
we are regulated submarines are safe
there are many companies that build them
and we dive down to very deep dips every
day but
if you are going to take shortcuts for
the sake of innovation
well you know we might look like old
fuddy Duds but you know there's a
there's if you add a bit of wisdom to
boldness uh
it helps everybody out all right will
Conan of the Marine technology Society
thank you
you're welcome
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is St John's Newfoundland
and Labrador where the Titan submersible
started its final Journey the last
adventure for those on board thanks for
watching bye-bye
[Music]
foreign